i can say to
all of you there is no part of me
that thinks that was the right way
to
behave
in that moment
will smith breaks his silence months
after that infamous oscar slap
now the actor has a direct message for
fans and host chris rock explaining why
he didn't apologize sooner
it's
it's it's all fuzzy i've reached out to
chris um
and the mesh the message that came back
is that uh he's not ready to talk
and when he is
he will
reach out
so i will i will say to you
chris
i
apologize
to you
my behavior
was
unacceptable
and i'm here
whenever you're ready to talk many fans
speculated it was will's wife jada
pinkett smith who encouraged him to
react physically
my deepest hope is that these two
intelligent capable men have an
opportunity to heal talk this out
and reconcile the slap stems from
chris's joke about jada's shaved head a
hairstyle she rocks because she suffers
from alopecia a hair loss condition but
will clears things up and says that's
not the case
after jada rolled her eyes did she tell
you to do something
no
it's like
you know i'm i made a choice
on my own
from my own experiences from
my
history with chris jada had nothing to
do with it i'm sorry babe
and the apologies continue will
addresses how his behavior brought heat
to his own family it takes practice to
have those difficult conversations but
he's especially remorseful for how he
impacted the rock family i want to
apologize to
chris's mother you know i wasn't
thinking but how many people got hurt
in that moment i want to apologize to
chris's family
specifically tony rock you know we had a
great relationship
but things went sour shortly after the
oscars tony posting on twitter that he
wasn't exactly a fan of will's written
apology when a fan asks do you approve
of the apology tony simply wrote no
we'll have to wait and see if the rock
family has anything to say about will's
latest apology but in the meantime will
who won best actor that night for his
role in king richard also apologized to
his fellow nominees it's like i won
because you you voted for me and it it
really breaks my heart to have stolen
and and tarnished tarnished your moment
i can still see
quest love's
eyes you know it happened on quest
love's
award and it's like i'm i'm
i'm sorry really isn't
sufficient
after months of deep reflection will
explains disappointing people is his
central trauma he says nothing hurt him
more than letting his fans down it hurts
me psychologically and emotionally to
know i didn't live up to
[Music]
people's
image and impression of me
i am
deeply remorseful
and i'm trying to be remorseful without
being ashamed of myself
right i'm a human
and
i made
a mistake
and i'm trying not to think of myself as
a piece of
moving forward will says he's focused on
spreading light love and joy
if you hang on i promise we'll be able
to be friends
[Music]
again you